McElligott: It'd be great if you could tell us
what it's like on site.
Are all the observations firsthand?
Are there cameras around?
What's the nature, what's the size,
what's the nature of the conditions?
Lonsdorf: When you are, this is
how it works at Gombe,
it's a little bit different at Karisoke in Rwanda
because they're, they have limited time with the gorillas.
But what I do when I'm at Gombe
is that I wake up very early in the morning.
We know where the chimps have slept the night before
because they actually build a night nest in the trees,
and if you follow them
until late in the day when they build that nest
you're like,
"Great, that's where you'll be at 6AM tomorrow."
So you wake up so that you're with them at 6AM.
And what our on-site researchers do is
they follow a single kind of focal individual all day,
from the time they get up till the time they go to bed.
And they're taking a series of consistent data
every 15 minutes.
But then taking longhand data
throughout the day about interesting things like mating and grooming and fighting and all that kind of stuff.
So you're on foot in the  morning,
a chimp comes down from the tree.
Wake up time is a really good time
to collect fecal samples, by the way.
Just makes sense if you think about it, right?
So you get there in the morning,
collect all your samples.
Then you're with the chimps all day.
You're following them at a distance of about 7 meters.
That's what we consider a safe distance for them
and for us. They break it often
because you're either in their way or they're curious.
So like me to the fourth row.
And you're with them and recording
everything they do all day.
Now we have several teams out,
we have a team focused on the adults.
And we have a specific team focused on
mothers and kids as part of this grant.
So there's gonna be multiple teams out in the day
following individual chimpanzees around.
Documenting their behavior
where they go, what they eat.
Collecting samples all day.
And that has been going on
essentially unchanged since 1966.
McElligott: And you're based in Pennsylvania but you're out there...?
Lonsdorf: I'm out there once a year.
When I was a student, I could go more.
But then I invested in my own offspring and it all went downhill from there.
McElligott: These expensive children. We've got another question in the
back there.
QUESTION: Thanks very much for the talk. I'm interested in childbirth,
Could you talk a little bit about it?
Sociology, where the mother goes?
McElligott: Just make sure you're holding the mic closer we can hear you.
QUESTION: Childbirth...how many individuals are around when the infant is born. First treatments...
Lonsdorf: The question is about childbirth and the act of childbirth
and how that happens in apes and in chimpanzees.
Interestingly enough, a colleague of mine is finalizing
a paper and analysis of that right now.
But it's highly variable.
So the important thing to point out about chimpanzees is that they are extremely aggressive
within their own community.
And infanticide is a real risk.
From stranger chimpanzees, but also from chimpanzees in your community,
both males and females.
So a newborn baby is incredibly vulnerable.
Its mother is subject to infanticidal attacks.
So because of that what often happens is that
mom goes on a bit of a maternity leave
and wants to be by herself.
When she gives birth to that baby.
Now we of course have outliers. We have a very—had, she's passed away now—a very dominant female
named Fifi who had more babies than anybody else.
She's the one in that picture touching Jane.
She's kind of the best documented animal on the planet.
Very comfortable in her community
and also with humans.
And she would give birth like right in front of tourists.
Her sons were always alpha male,
she wasn't worried about this infanticidal thing.
McElligott: Rock star behavior
Lonsdorf: Yeah. But typically
there is a real maternity leave. And we don't know much about it.
Because if they decide to be
where we can't find them, we can't find them.
So I can't answer your question really well,
because we don't get to see it very much.